these days Hollywood seems to operate
under the premise that you can never
have too much of a good thing if people
like a film well that means you could
expect a dozen sequels to be announced
but sometimes things don't go as
expected here's a look at some plans
trilogies that sadly will never be
completed Hellboy if there's an unmade
sequel out there that fans truly want to
see its Hellboy 3 del Toro's Hellboy 2
the Golden Army was released in July
2008 starring Ron Perlman is the nut
quite horned hero
it received overwhelmingly positive
reviews from critics and grossed over
160 million dollars worldwide on an
estimated 85 million dollar production
budget but even though the movie was a
modest success for del Toro it wasn't a
monster hits so Universal Pictures never
commissioned a third installment since
then both del Toro and Perlman have
publicly lobbied to make a third Hellboy
but nothing has come of it still hope
springs eternal
in January of 2017 del Toro asked his
Twitter followers to weigh in on the
possibility of a third Hellboy movie
after getting more than 132,000
responses del Toro and Pearlman
approached Hellboy creator Mike Minneola
to discuss the possibility of a third
film but there have been plenty of
hopeful meetings before and after nearly
a decade of waiting it's starting to
look like this one would never actually
happen amazing spider-man despite
critics and audiences largely detesting
Sam Raimi spider-man 3 Tobey Maguire at
least got the chance to conclude his
spider-man trilogy
that's something Andrew Garfield would
never get to do because in 2015 Sony
Pictures suspended plans to expand the
amazing spider-man franchise and instead
opted to share the character with Marvel
Studios as a result we now have Tom
Holland playing a new spider-man in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe and a rebooted
spider-man film series that officially
kicks off with spider-man homecoming in
2017 but what were sony's original plans
prior to Marc Webb's the amazing
spider-man 2 in 2014 a Sony plan to
launch an extended spider-man franchise
to compete with the Marvel Cinematic
Universe it was going to include two
more amazing spider-man films as well as
for venom and the sinister six sony also
hired Westworld co-creator Lisa joy
Nolan to write a script for our female
character movie set in the spider-man
universe Burton nothing has since come
of it
although the studio canceled plans to
pursue more amazing spider-man films
they haven't shuttered all the
spider-man spin-off films in March 2016
as Sony confirmed they were moving
forward with the venom film however that
don't appear to be plans to have the
movie connect to Eva the amazing
spider-man films or the Marvel Cinematic
Universe Trials just don't do anything I
would do and definitely don't do
anything I wouldn't do there's a little
gray area in there and that's where you
operate national treasure jon turteltaub
slow growl take on Indiana Jones was a
surprise hit in 2004 and the 2007 sequel
national treasure Book of Secrets
performed even better bringing in almost
four hundred and sixty million dollars
worldwide the success prompted Disney to
commissioned a sequel the following year
and with the studium acquiring domain
names for national treasures three and
four rumors began to spread that the
Mouse House was eyeing back-to-back
sequels although turteltaub was
interested in making another national
treasure film he said they were going to
take their time and get the story right
before moving forward explaining in an
interview until we have a great story a
great adventure and a great piece of
history to explore there's no point in
making the movie a decade later it still
hasn't happened Tron
it took almost 30 years but in 2010
Disney finally released a sequel to
their 1982 cult classic Tron starring
Garrett Hedlund Olivia Wilde and Jeff
Bridges Tron Legacy earned average
critic reviews and modest box office
success it wasn't a failure but it
wasn't a big enough hit for Disney to
move forward with a third film but the
thing is Tron Legacy writers Edward
kitsis
and Adam Horowitz had already begun
working on a script for a third film
before legacy even released not long
after legacy hits Ain't It Cool News
reported that Disney was gearing up to
announce Tron 3 but the announcement
never arrived instead after five years
of dragging their feet
Disney finally announced the series was
dead
hey who knows maybe they'll bring it
back again in thirty more years kick-ass
director Matthew Vaughn and star Aaron
taylor-johnson brought the comic book
series kick-ass to life on the big
screen in 2008 praised for its adult
themes kick-ass received positive
reviews from critics and managed to
become a modest box-office success
prompting Universal to move forward with
a sequel kick-ass 2 meanwhile was
released in August 2013 to negative
reviews and declining box office sales
shortly before the release of kick-ass 2
the comic books writer confirmed that
plans for a third movie would largely
depend upon how much money the second
movie earned
later that month reports of plans for a
third installment surfaced saying
kick-ass 3 would conclude the kick-ass
trilogy with a major death after the
film's disappointing results though
those plans were put on hold along with
a rumored hit go prequel that does not
kick ass 28 months later five years
after danny boyle's 28 days later hit
theaters the sequel 28 weeks later
arrived depicting a nato takeover of the
UK where they supposedly quota zombie
infestation unfortunately one person
infected with the virus survived and
managed to spread it to the remaining
survivors at the end of the movie a
handful of survivors escaped England and
make it to France however one of them
was still a carrier for the infection
allowing the infection to spread across
the channel ending the film on a
cliffhanger
shortly after 28 weeks later released
coil indicated that plans for a third
instalment were in the works
unfortunately screenwriter Alex Garland
believes her room at twenty eight months
later movie won't happen due to
copyright issues when we made 28 days
later the rights were frozen between a
group of people who are no longer
talking to each other
still Garland and Boyle are still
talking about doing a third film if
those legal issues can ever get resolved
we'll see ghostbusters the first
Ghostbusters movie ranks as one of the
most beloved films in history in fact
the u.s. Library of Congress selected
the original Ghostbusters for
preservation in the National Film
registry in 2015 for being quotes
culturally historically or aesthetically
significant end quote it became a
worldwide phenomenon follow
1984 release which prompted Columbia
Pictures to commission a sequel and
while Ghostbusters 2 wasn't as well
received by critics as the first movie
it was still a hit earning over 215
million dollars worldwide on an
estimated 37 million dollar production
budget despite the success however
director ivan reitman didn't have any
immediate plans to make a third
installment flash-forward 10 years and
series star and writer dan Aykroyd
finished a 122 page draft for
ghostbusters 3 hell-bent it appeared
that they were finally making progress
on a third film but Bill Murray was
reportedly and interested in making
another Ghostbusters it was then rumored
that Ben Stiller could replace Murray in
the sequel alongside Aykroyd and Harold
Ramis nothing came of the idea though
and after the death of Egan actor Harold
Ramos in 2014 writes Minh officially
backed out of directing Ghostbusters 3
though he agreed to stay on as a
producer after approaching a few
directors Sony decided to move forward
with a soft reboot of the franchise
instead without Ramos it looks as though
the original team as busted as last
ghost regardless of the controversy
surrounding the 2016 reboot at least
there were 7 seasons of the Real
Ghostbusters 1 season of extreme
Ghostbusters and 2009 s Ghostbusters 2
video game that tells more stories
featuring our favorite paranormal
investigators and eliminators Fantastic
Four after achieving global success with
the x-men series 20th Century Fox hopes
to build off those movies hype by moving
forward with a Fantastic Four series the
first Fantastic Four movie released in
2005 two mixed reviews however fan
anticipation led the Fantastic Four to
become a box office success earning over
three times as production budget that
success inevitably led Fox to
commissioned a sequel titled Fantastic
Four rise of the Silver Surfer director
Tim story and the rest of the casting
crew or return for the 2007 follow-up
but it was man
best earning mixed reviews and the
mediocre box office story wanted to move
forward with a third film but Fox
decided against it opting instead to put
the franchise on hold before eventually
rebooting it in 2015 of josh trank of
course that move backfired
well fantastically the new version
became a critical punching bag and a box
office disaster should have stuck with
the original after all that's gross
Kill Bill Quentin Tarantino likes to
make a single story at a time moving
from one project to another without
thinking about sequels however just a
few short months prior to killbill
releasing in theaters Tarantino and
Miramax concluded that his four hour
film would have to be split into two
releases vers Kill Bill volume 1 and
Kill Bill volume 2 were born although
they aren't his most commercially
successful films the series has become a
cult hit in the years since its release
the second film ends on an unexpected up
notes with Beatrix and her daughter
heading off to live a life of peace
however Tarantino believes there's
always room for more in 2004 he
indicated plans to make a volume 3 with
uma Thurman reprising her role as the
bride though he said he would probably
wait around 15 years before making
another one baby you Inc over the next
few years
Tarantino hinted he still had a plans to
make a third Kill Bill with the story
potentially focusing on the revenge of
two killers whose arms and eyes were
hacked by Omer Fuhrman in the first
stories or maybe a revenge story
featuring the daughter of Vernita green
turning the tables and hunting down
Thurman but nothing ever came of either
idea in 2012
Tarantino finally conceded I don't know
if there's ever going to be a Kill Bill
Vol 3 and that of course led to
Tarantino's fans to do this
thanks for watching click the loop icon
to subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
your love to